[Music]
and now 10 urban dictionary definitions
you need to know
fart lapse the period of time between
who dealt it and who smelt it the fart
laps on Jack's silent but deadly was a
full eight seconds armpit ease breasts
that slide to the side while lying on
one's back Cortney sleeps on her stomach
to avoid getting armpit e's postponed
running late due to an unscheduled
sexual encounter Jim was postponed for
his job interview by a quickie with
Jenny vapid extras the ability to
masturbate with equal efficiency using
either hand
Jim listed farid extras on his resume
under special skills Just Ducky calm on
the surface paddling like crazy
underneath Jim didn't get the job so
he's just ducky ear boner when a dog's
ears perk up Roxy gets an ear boner
every time I jiggle my bag of treats
friend scaping trimming one's friends
list on social media jenny dropped a
bunch of ratchet ass chicks in her last
round of friends gaping anti-stalking to
learn someone's routine to
systematically avoid them jenny is
anti-stalking her ex until he dies ABC
sex sex only on anniversaries birthdays
and Christmas Tom and Sue have been
married so long they only have ABC sex
literally a word often confused with
figuratively I literally cannot believe
how many people miss U's literally for
more definitions visit
urbandictionary.com while you're there
be sure to look up French microphone
it makes me giggle
[Music]